there was some concerns
um
that if this was to pass it might be too
big a burden on the commission so we
just want to go through we did receive a
fact sheet there's some data on the case
percentage so like to go through that
and just understand how big a burden
would that be is it real is it perceived
and are there any things that we need to
uh to plug also wanted to talk a little
bit about um the 180 day wait time uh
just to kind of
get everybody's thoughts on that and
then lastly we did receive a process map
which basically goes through how the
operation at the commission might be
streamlined so just want to kind of play
that out how does that contrast with the
current operations uh what and what's
everybody's kind of thoughts on that
then we'll go into some open discussion
and we'll take it from there so is
everybody okay with that
okay so first um
i just
want to kind of go through the first
thing that we talked about in uh our
organizational meeting uh back in june
was the fact that there may be a lot of
issues
at the human rights commission that are
below the surface and so representative
dilorenzo
asked would it be possible to have a
performance audit done
and as we talked a little bit in june we
thought that there might be some merits
to that i did have a zoom meeting over
the summer with the state director of
audits director smith
where he did mention
that that might be
worthwhile they had done a financial
audit in the past
and they couldn't really go over into
the performance side because that would
have taken them out of the scope of the
financial audit
so i guess the agency that
directs
which state audits are undertaken uh is
the lpoc apparently they're at the call
of the chair so they're going to be
meeting again
in
october i dashed a
note off to senator regan uh with
respect to getting us put on the agenda
i haven't had any response back from him
um but i will be following up tomorrow
on veto day with representative
umbricker who's also on that committee
just to you know
understand what do we need to do to make
sure that we're on the agenda and
when as activity goes forward with that
i'll definitely keep the rest of the
committee up to speed on that
the other thing i did have a meeting at
the human rights commission itself uh
with the staff at the invitation of
director malachi
and you know that was a that was a very
productive meeting
i got to understand you know a lot of
the challenges that they are facing
there they have done certain things um
at the um commission to try to
accelerate the time that it takes
to move through the process
they they've cut the caseload from 50
down to 20 to 25. uh also i believe
they're staffed now with uh five
investigators where they had been
staffed at two they so they're pretty
much staffed at the full complement
they're looking um at adding more
resources there with respect to that so
um
and so it
it would be interesting to see um how
kind of restructuring because in the
past the case load being 50
they would just
let things go and sometimes things could
kind of drag having just 20 cases in
folks hands but i don't really know if
we have a good feel at this point for
what that's really going to do to the
the speed at getting things through to a
probable cause hearing
i did meet following that
with
new hampshire associate of justice and
different lawyers groups with respect to
some of their observations and findings
and subsequent to that
we did have um
a couple of emails sent out from marisa
chase with the association for justice
including uh
a fact sheet on uh sb 292 which
basically is looking at the removal rate
and they provided some data around that
and also they provided a roadmap which
they feel would allow people to get
through to the probable cause finding uh
in one year uh and the current statute
is two and of course you know we're not
we're not at that two year point at this
time so as as we get through i'd like to
in in the later part of the agenda just
kind of go through
uh that
uh
that roadmap and and talk about um
thoughts on it uh where it's strong
where it's weak and if there were
strengths to it how would those uh
strengths be implemented what was the
mechanism by which that could happen
um so that's kind of
uh where we were
with respect to uh the activity from the
summer i think though one of the things
that
um
having spoken to the people that i've
spoken to
um
really
just
in terms of the scope of where this
subcommittee should go i think really it
just at this point needs to stay into
296 so there might be other issues that
we have at the human rights commission i
really think um that's kind of beyond
the ability of this committee to get
into
so i think really the scope on this is
just 296. what do we need to do to make
it work
and
then let the performance audit come
through and do the rest
so kind of with with those with that
kind of summary recap and statement of
purpose i'd open up for members of the
committee does anybody have any thoughts
agreements disagreements
um
additional comments
yes representative lorenzo
thank you mr cure i have one quick
question are we being recorded
um
and i only ask because i think that i
might want to look back on a tape for
reference because we've got a lot of
stuff to him too and in here
do you know are we being recorded
okay
okay okay
great thank you that's it
other questions or thoughts
okay
no
ned would be fine he's mr chair
it's all good
based on your introductory comments you
said that having met with the commission
uh you found that they had cut their
case load from 50 to 25
and i was curious as to
how that came about how did since we
have
discussed in the fact that they have
this large caseload how did they go
about cutting the case though well
basically it's my understanding and
director malachi can can step in at any
point is
they
those cases still exist
but they are unassigned and so what they
were finding was that um
if the investigator had 50 cases
then
it was just a mush and everything was
just kind of out there and so when they
would put in for example a request for
information from a respondent the
respondent might not get back to them
right away and because they had so many
cases out there they would just kind of
leave that out there
so the thinking was um and again
director malachi you can chime up
the thinking was if i'm just focused on
20 cases that allows me to attack those
with greater clarity but it does not
mean that the amount of cases that are
being you know held within the purview
of the human rights commission has
diminished it just means that the amount
of active cases that each investigator
has has essentially been cut in half so
does that answer your question
i i think it does but basically
they haven't reduced their caseload
they're just reduced the number of cases
individuals who are employed there are
handling
yeah so i'd say maybe the the active
cases have been cut in half is that a
fair statement yeah the active case
doesn't cut in half
i'll defer to representative smith yes
representative smith
thank you first of all i'd like to thank
you very much for the time you have put
into this over the last few months it's
been incredible
and it's not as if this is your day job
so i really want to thank you for that
um
you had mentioned this same
uh
situation to me and i
i was troubled by it but thought that i
might have missed something
i know you talked about
efforts to get more staff people in and
i might have conflated the fact that
well if they're more staff people then
they're more people with
to divide the cases among
but i think we have to be careful about
the language we use um
all
if i'm correct and i hope i'm not but if
i'm correct then all that is being said
is that half of the cases
are going to be ignored they're going to
be put on the shelf
and will focus on
another half and
meanwhile new cases are coming in
so
i don't see this as
the caseload
being
decreased it all i see it as the
caseload staying the same
but decisions for whatever reason made
to ignore half of the cases
tell me i'm wrong
no i i i think you're correct i think
that the decision was made at the human
rights commission
that for any investigator to have active
cases
to have 50 active cases in front of them
is just too much
um
for any person to have in front of them
so they are holding cases back to allow
the investigators to be
more focused and the hope is that by
being more focused they're going to be
able to go through them at at a quicker
rate but you're right they they are
being they're being they're still held
at the commission and the new cases that
come in it's still on a first in first
out basis
so that means that those go to the back
of the queue
that to me that would mean that new
cases coming in are going to be even
more at a disadvantage
because it's going to take
even more time did you in in our
conversations mr did you indicate
anything about a change in
staffing
um the
the the director has put in a request to
increase staffing i think uh director
you were saying you were looking for
nine investigators was what you're
looking to try to go to
total total of nine so it's it's my
understanding right now that uh the
commission is staffed to five
investigators
and so there is a request to move that
to nine
so what is the process on
of getting the additional um
investigators on board is that does that
have to be like in the budget or
whatever what's the process
i don't know the the budget process i
think the funding request comes in does
that have to wait for a budget year
yeah yeah so mr chair
this is
a year when um
the the biennial budget is drawn up
to go into effect
starting july 1st
so at a time when my understanding is
that the state is having trouble hiring
people
finding people willing to work for the
state
at whatever salary levels
it's not until um
10 months from now
that you could even start the process of
um
of having um
uh
admin administrative services you know
create the jobs improve the jobs start
the hiring process it is conceivable
you're talking again
of two years from now
before this changes and um
it's
i'm very
very troubled
the classic understanding that every one
of us who believes in in this process
has is that justice delayed is justice
denied
and it's not just in criminal matters
it's in all matters and
i
i actually see
the suggestion of putting half the cases
on the shelf
as
even more negative
than the situation they have now i i
wish i had had time
to prep to to read and evaluate the
material that um
that jen just gave us
um
comparing the process um
uh between the human rights commission
and the department of labor
um
i i think of
why we created things like the housing
that the housing appeals board
to speed things up to say
we've got to do this more quickly if
we're going to be fair
i
i am heartsick that people who think
that they can turn to the state
because they believe
rightly or wrongly
that they have a human rights complaint
nothing can be more personal and more
threatening than that
to find themselves in a situation where
for whatever reason
with that the lack of resources um
confusion about process
uh
they are not good
forget about justice delayed it's
justice ignored so
i'm not happy and
when i add that to what the little i
understand and i'm the first person to
say i might be confused
it seems to me
about two years gets taken up
just to kind of figure out if maybe we
should think about the possibility that
there might be something worth
looking at
um
there are all these steps that
that i i i'm
i'm not being articulate i'm sorry i
apologize
yeah surveillance park thank you mr
chairman so
uh i absolutely concur what
representative smith has said
and and really i think that it's that
concern
that has driven us to to to where we are
today
i think the issue of whether or not the
respondent can remove cases
at the latter stages of the hrc process
stimulated us
but i think we could have dealt with
that
had it not been for this issue that just
seems to be
uh beyond our capability to fix
because we aren't the executive branch
we can't
say
and especially not in an interim study
we can't say no the department's got to
put 15 more people which might be the
the right answer to this is put 15 more
people on that job right away
to cut down the backlog and make it
something that's manageable
we can't
out of this study committee
say geez i looked at what they do in
other states and they somehow or they
get these things done in a year
because they have timelines and
deadlines that have to be met all the
way through that we don't have
we can't make those things happen
and it's frustrating
absolutely agree
so
i think that what we can do
is make recommendations for what we
think maybe should happen
and that's about as far as we can
actually go
and for me
having and i i read through all that
stuff that the association for justice
sent out in the packet that's here on
the table and i looked at the numbers
and the stuff from the association for
justice and
for me
the only answer i can see to this is
that we have to a expedite the process
by setting up making a process because
the process we have now is not clearly
not working so you need a new process
they need a new process with a much
tighter process with much tighter
deadlines
they need at least a short term
thumping staff
to reduce their backlog
back
is that right whatever backlog back
thank you
all right those things are necessary and
and i think that's about as far as we
can go and as far and we could actually
try and deal with this idea of the
respondent being able to remove
um i like some of the things i saw from
other states in that but
i don't think it takes us very long to
conclude that that's what we should be
doing
representative gordon
well
uh i i just took a
a couple of things i think
one one
only to disagree briefly with my
distinguished colleague about we can't
do something because we're not the
executive branch the human rights
commission was created by the
legislature
it and
we established the statutes that govern
the human rights commission and i think
it's our responsibility to make sure
that the human rights commission works
properly
and so
i think we have that duty i i am a
little concerned about saying we're
going to wait till the audits completed
before we do anything because i think
they're is a should be a greater sense
of urgency
to deal with the issues
i think uh
the idea you know having read
through the materials that we did have
in advance today the
stuff that came from the
practicing attorneys
you know changing the statute from two
years to one year
i i don't know that that has any effect
because the two years being ignored
today so why wouldn't one year be just
as ignored as two years so
um
that's just not happening so
this is
i come from a background uh
the court background so my court
background
the biggest issue that i've seen in
terms of this delay all comes down to
this issue of investigators and the time
that it's taking to come up with just
not a result resolution but just a
probable cause determination
and and i understand we just got
something from the labor board but
typically in other boards and typically
in the courts
the parties are responsible for
discovery
and
not
to
not the individual commission or the
board is responsible to do all the
investigation and the work the party
should be responsible for that
and i understand in these types of cases
where you have individuals who may not
be represented in many of those cases
that
we would want to support them by out
having somebody do the investigation for
them
but it seems to me that we could
practically
decide to appoint attorneys for these
people and have them do discovery
probably at a lesser expense than we're
currently
having to have investigators and get the
job done and get it done more quickly
it seems to me that there are positive
changes that could be made i mean
significant changes
for me
i would rather not just say okay
we're just going to make a
recommendation that yeah we ought to
have further legislation about whether
or not
to
indicate that one party cannot
remove it to the other court i
i think
we should go beyond that that's my
personal preference go beyond that and
deal with what i think is
really an urgent need in the state for
change in this particular body because
people i fully agree with representative
smith
we're not providing people with justice
in this state and that's that's that's
just not right
representative lorenzo thank you mr
chair and i've had a few quick thoughts
um
and one is that could the investigators
come from the attorney general's office
that's one thought
another thought that i had it's not
parallel but um when director malachi
announced that um that case loads were
cut in half i thought i had this analogy
in my mind of
when um i left lucy was working in a
chocolate factory and they had to convey
about the chocolates going and she
couldn't keep up with the conveyor belt
and that's the picture that i have in my
mind of um
you know the case load being cut
and
and that's not to say that's not to
look at the hrc um
in a deprecative
manner but to
my my aim is to help
the hrc
with with this issue
thank you
thank you representative so i think you
know if we look at the agenda um that
we're going to kind of go through today
the first thing is just looking at 296
itself uh to see what can we do
with respect to that
and so i think
that's the first part uh but then the
next part of uh the agenda we are going
to get into process um so we're going to
talk about that streamlining memorandum
and you know representative gordon we're
going to talk about what is the
threshold for probable cause how does it
differ and there may be opportunities um
you know within the subcommittee
um and so if we
kind of plumb those depths and we find
that there are things that we can do
and that are workable um i'm i'm not
opposed to to going forward with that
understanding you know that we have the
resources that we have and so um so i
think that's kind of where i'm at with
that does anybody else have any other
thoughts before we kind of you know dash
into the next part of the agenda
i just would make one more comment and
that was i was absolutely shocked
at the
number of hearings that are being held
by the human rights commission
or lack of hearings i should say
absolutely shocked and if i were to go
to
the
member of the public and say well how
many cases do you currently have pending
in the human rights commission
and they were to tell me
and i said well how many hearings did
you have last year and they said three
then
i
i i i'm just i i just have to say that
my only comment is i'm just absolutely
astounded by that
and you know and i think that that's one
of the reasons why i i asked uh
jen if she could kind of go through to
look at the comparative path with with
the labor board um where they and she's
still kind of gathering that data but at
least we have a a
a map of the process but definitely they
do have more hearings but what are the
different thresholds is is that
something that we can leverage and i
think we can talk a little bit through
that you know amongst ourselves and
amongst the expertise we have in the
audience today
representative smith
can i ask questions it might be of um
the former judge um
i
i read through the stuff that we had
before today so that doesn't include
this document which i think is going to
be very interesting
and it seemed to me
that
the commission
with all
you know deliberate commitment to
the people who come before it
doing the same thing twice
they go through a very complicated time
long time process
to get what i will as a layperson just
refer to as a preliminary
finding which isn't the technical term i
understand and then they start again and
go through the whole thing am i
misunderstanding that
are you asking me
i'm asking you because you're familiar
more familiar than i am
right
it it is not uncommon
in
the court system particularly in
criminal matters
to make a probable cause determination
before a case goes forward
so
having a probable cause determination is
not
unusual
but
in a criminal case
the complaint is made and generally that
in a felony a probable cause hearing has
to be made
within 20 days
yeah i think
i think
you're right
representative smith in that there is a
huge amount of investigation
that goes in on the part of uh the human
rights commission for it's a finding of
probable cause so it's it's it's
definitely a different ballpark so we
can
when we talked when i was at the
commission we talked about some uh
investigations that they go out two
years depending upon the complexity of
the investigation so you're talking
some very very heavy investigation on
some of these more complex cases towards
going
to finding a probable cause and so it
kind of runs the gamut
other thoughts
representative walper thank you mr
chairman i'd just like to
just take that thread and pull it a
little bit
because
the standard of could we could
could not should but could
a reasonable person
find that there is probable cause
it's a very low standard it seems to me
it would be very easy
to say well yeah reasonable it doesn't
take much to say that a reasonable
person could find that
right but yet
we're taking a very long time to to even
reach that without with what i think of
as a very preliminary judgment that
could be done in a
i don't know an interview with you with
the complainant and a phone call
or two right
so i know i i take your point and but
we're gonna i want to follow up as we
get later on uh in in the work session
and we talk about process so i want to
kind of hold those thoughts you know
for that point i want to revisit that
as we look at the process and what is
that threshold we can kind of flush that
later on in the work session but first i
just want to get before i get into that
i want to get into 296 itself
and just kind of look at that
what was the bill what would be the
burden on the human rights commission um
if if it was to uh come into being does
it need to be tweaked and then as i said
later on we're going to talk about the
process map
some thoughts about the process map and
we can talk about that threshold okay
all right so moving on
i just kind of want to go through um
the uh the fact sheet on uh sb 296.
so
miss j is it would you be willing to
come up and talk about that a little bit
or have somebody come up and just kind
of walk us through
some of the findings on that
would you mind just sharing some of your
thoughts on it
feel free
so as we've talked about today
process is taking investigation process
well the assignment process is taking a
long time the investigation process is
taking a long time
eventually some folks are getting pc
findings and the respondent is
removing
the complainant
to court
starting the whole process all over
again which of course is going to take
more time and that's the problem that
we're
we're tackling here um
oh no i've been i think we've all been
through this a couple of times now yes
the the
the um
the reason for sb 296 and the impact
that it has uh would
would have a
positive impact that would have on
claimants are there any specific
questions that i could answer any
anything um
from this sheet that that you have
questions about
no just uh looking at your thoughts i
mean as i go through
i think what what came out for me and
then i'll just make my comment and then
i'll i'll open it up to uh the rest of
the committee members and and folks in
the audience what i'm looking at from
the time that i was um at the commission
they kind of walked me through and it
was my understanding that your intake
rate was about say maybe 25 cases a
month or in that ballpark would you say
you know
so that's so we're looking at an intake
rate after they go through they
they get hundreds and hundreds of calls
but that's basically the intake rate um
and so if i'm looking here at any given
calendar year with respondent or moving
to court post finding
which really is what we're talking about
that's the the original sb 296 is saying
this is what i'm going to do i'm going
to take that away and so that now
becomes
the whatever burden
of the the commission to pick up i'm
looking at
13 you know i say 300 6 out of 300 1 out
of 307
so um as a percentage of the intake rate
the removal rate is pretty low so
just looking at
the data
um i'm not thinking
that from a resource perspective it's
going to be a big hit
so
um i guess
yes representative i would say that that
is our what i hear from our employment
attorneys as well that's our belief
so so i would just give director malachi
um
a chance to kind of share her thoughts
because she's actually living it um
based on on on those numbers what what
are your feelings uh at that removal
rate uh that the burden would be on the
commission
do you want us to switch representative
sure yeah
yeah you could go over there if you want
okay
okay so thank you very much for the
question ani malachi executive director
human rights commission
so
just in a nutshell
intake
once a call comes in
those things are processed very quickly
once a case is assigned we also move
through that fairly quickly
minus any a tremendous amount in some
instances of back and forth with
attorneys primarily with with
complainants attorneys we have a lot
of amendments and such but it's the
middle part
so
to answer your question specifically
if we were to have more hearings if
respondent
needed to remain at the commission
then we would have more hearings
to representative gordon or chair
gordon's point
at him being saddened or upset or
i don't want to put words in his mouth
about the low number of hearings it is
because primarily we are an
administrative process so people have a
variety of opportunities along the way
to settle and we're happy when they
settle
so we don't bar them from settling so it
doesn't go from intake to hearing
because if that were the case we'd have
a ton of hearings but there's a process
for the respondent to say we don't agree
with this allegation and for the
complainant to respond back to that and
go back and forth we do the
investigation
and if you look at the settle rate most
of our cases do settle whether it's in
mediation or the judge would understand
conciliation which is after a probable
cause finding we always schedule those
cases once it hits probable cause we'll
schedule them for a hearing but then
there's still an opportunity
between the time probable cause is found
and the hearing for them to settle and
the majority of them do settle which is
why we don't either the majority settle
some will be removed and then those few
will remain with us and go through to a
hearing so
we will not it's
on the hearing side
that's not a
an exacerbating burden
so
representative smith you go first just
fine
thank you very much uh to that response
and i hope you know that as painful as
this discussion is for all of us
i think everyone in the room and i i
know everyone on this committee
wants the human relations commission
to
to do
what the legislature
created it to do which is to provide
a recourse to people who need help
and
so
when we sound frustrated or distressed
it's
at the circumstances it's not at you
i hope you understand that
um
if you get you get about 30
cases a year did you say no i mean
anywhere from 20 there are some months
we've had 30 um
an intake is we talk to everyone that
calls not every phone call turns into
charge so those those phone calls that
actually turn into charges there could
be anywhere from 20 to 30 a month it
really depends okay so if i could just
follow a couple i'm sorry
we also have attorney file charges so
sometimes the person doesn't call us and
they may seek an attorney and then the
attorney will construct the charge and
send it to us and we immediately file
that so that's in that number as well
okay so let's so at 20
times 12 that's about 240
cases a year
um
so looking at just
well actually 2021 is interesting
because it's not a full
year but let's just look at 2021 because
it's the end and it's easy for us
so you're saying
um
240 cases a year
you say that no probable cause
in 64.
probable cause
in 19 is that
part of what
we've been told
okay so that's eighty
three cases
um
what
out of two hundred
so that's my question
that that's my basic question so
200 you know 220 cases here we're
talking about 83 oh and then let's say
the
respondent removed
to court and cases resolved during
conciliation so that's another nine so
let's say 95 it's not quite 95 but let's
say not so that leaves 105
cases
unaccounted for or uncounted in this
and
what happens with them sure so um my
name is sarah burke cohen i am the
assistant director at the new hampshire
commission for human rights
thank you for your question
representative smith to to answer it is
like director malachi said we have a lot
of different pathways for our cases um
so these cases are cases that have what
gotten through what we call a full
investigation it means that
it has been investigated because it
hasn't gotten out of any of the other
avenues the commission is lucky enough
to have a free mediation program that we
have
had for a long time we've put together
for a long time we have volunteer
mediators that help mediate our cases so
oftentimes parties um will decide to
mediate the case to try to settle the
case and that is very successful our
success rate for that mediation program
is
at eighty percent
um so can i can i just finish just let
me finish um so the majority of our
cases we close about 240 cases a year so
we kind of strike even right on on cases
we're taking it excuse me in cases we
close okay the reason why they're not on
here is because they they settle or are
removed by complainant
prior to a finding so that means prior
to a finding of probable cause a
complainant has the opportunity to
remove it i know it says that uh
amending 354-a to eliminate the 180-day
wait period
so there is a hundred day-to-day wait
period for complainants to remove it
however a complainant can do it sooner
that than that with the consent of the
commission and some do
so we have a number of cases a
significant number of cases that's
settled and then some cases that are
removed by complainant and then those
that go through investigation are here
the 64 and 19.
that
could
that's very very helpful and i thank you
and
that then causes me to say
where
where has the backlog been stashed if
you're telling me that what comes in
equals what goes out
through different routes
then there should not be
a backlog so
where
what why is there a backlog so the
backlog that we've been carrying we've
been carrying since our budget was cut
in about 2011 and our staffing was cut
so the backlog started to come up there
not and with with staffing changes we've
had uh we've had some time some points
in our our history where we've only had
two investigators we've lost staff to
various things
as you know this you know when
it's hard to compete with private
industry so sometimes we lose staffing
to private industry so some of our
backlog is caused by our staffing that
we had limited staffing every year we
ask for additional staffing every budget
year we ask for additional staffing and
we haven't gotten that so our backlog
sort of has traveled with us because we
are at this 240 240. so we're getting
them in we're taking them out
and so it's it's difficult to overstep
that with the with the staffing we have
now
correct
so just and just to clarify the
the reconciliation
process that's happening
while the probable cause investigation
is going on so that's then you go to
conciliation after the probable cause
finding
so um
so again if the respondent just a quick
question then if the respondent
if it sounds
to me director malachi what you're
saying then is the impact of 296
is more on
the
reconciliation process that happens
after the probable cause finding so
right now if you're looking at
[Music]
cases resolved during conciliation if i
look at that line on the 296 fact sheet
i'm looking at say an average of 10
cases a year which are uh resolved by uh
conciliation right so so 10 cases a year
uh you're going through that
conciliation process
now
if those could not be
removed to court
those would be added in on top of that
number right so that's
what you're saying at the impact would
be to the commission itself in that
conciliation process
so
every average of ten a year
let's say i'm out looking just quick
eyeballing it if i have an average of
seven cases a year removed uh after uh
finding by the respondent i would be
adding that on to the uh
the conciliation
load yes not sure that i'm understanding
but
maybe this answers the question
our conciliation process would still
take place so there's still that
opportunity for settlement if i'm
understanding 296 it simply means that
they can't if conciliation fails they
are not able to remove it to court and
that they would remain with us to have a
hearing so they would still have
mediation before we even begin anything
they could still if there are two
attorneys involved they could still
settle if the complainant um is
interested in a settlement along the way
they can still make that known to their
investigator once there's a probable
cause we would still do
reconciliation if it settles it's done i
understand so what so so right now the
in the current process there's a
probable cause finding
the folks either remove or they stay
those that stay which is the bottom line
on on this sheet
um those that stay i'm looking at i'm
just doing a quick
eyeball math
an average of 10 cases are resolved
during conciliation per year so i'm
assuming that's the folks that stay
because you've only had
you know three hearings the bulk of it
is resolved by conciliation so i'm
assuming that and that's about 10 cases
a year
if
the respondent
is not able to remove if that's taken
away
the line right above it i have 2015 i
had 13 cases 2016 six cases 2017 one so
let's say on average
i have about seven cases a year right
now that are currently removed that
would go away
if 296 were to pass
so that would be added
now to the line below and that is the
real burden
that the
commission would face if this was the
past am i am i over simplifying things
or is that
i'm not sure that i understand what
you're saying and so all right look
representative maybe you can explain it
better than i can so go for it
well no uh so all i can do is is say
that i am more confused now than i was
before
and the reason is because
what you're trying to get at it says
it's responding remove the court
post-finding
does that mean post-finding of probable
cause where they actually had a probable
cause hearing yes and probably found
probable cause
no
no no
that isn't what it means after finding
that means after a finding of probable
cause there is no hearing and a finding
of probable cause
after the investigation
there is a probable cause or no probable
cause
determination thank you that's a better
word
if there's a probable cause
determination
then there are three things that could
take place
um
if it is always scheduled for a hearing
it is always scheduled for a
conciliation
and after probable cause
yes
no hearing which is separate a hearing
is it's as if you are going to court
it's a brand new hearing on the matter
so there are people who had nothing to
do with the investigation
nothing to do with the elements of the
case that are listening to both sides
coming together to to provide their
evidence
to say
um
to to have a determination in their
favor all right so let me try to clarify
so what
okay so what happens is
a case is docketed before the human
rights commission it's going to sit in
it's going to sit in limbo for a while
until an investigator is assigned
the investigator is assigned the
investigator is going to do an
investigation that investigation could
take six months that investigation could
take two years depending upon the
complexity of the case at the end of
that two year or six month period
whatever it is
there is a finding of probable cause or
there is not a finding of probable cause
okay
is what representative mclean just said
accurate
let me yes i think i i'm fairly certain
it is so we we investigate we
investigate a case right case comes in
let me go let me let me
let me throw it through the beginning so
case comes in as a as of charge right a
charge is filed it's docketed with a
commission
so there's a period of time where it it
is unassigned it gets assigned to an
investigator the investigator
investigates talks to both parties talks
to witnesses reads all the documents
makes makes a recommendation to our on
our one of our commissioners who makes a
finding uh i'm sorry i'm gonna use
determination here a determination of
whether there's probable cause or no
probable pause probable cause moves it
along in the process towards a public
hearing
and so at after probable cause like um
the probable cause determination is made
as a director malachi
said we schedule it for a conciliation
a mandatory conciliation and a public
hearing because the public hearing is is
what
makes the final finding we'll use that
maybe that that will help if we use
determination probably cause
determination and finding finding being
after the public hearing so
these cases that are removed by either
complainant or respondent take place in
that sort of interlude between the
determination of probable cause and the
public hearing
so sometimes parties remove it before
the conciliation sometimes parties want
to stay and try to try to mediate the
case and try to settle the case
conciliate the case and settle it
this number of removals by respondents
is kind of a mixed bag of of those
sometimes respondents will wait and try
to settle the case at conciliation and
sometimes they will just remove it right
before the conciliation
does that make sense
i hope i helped
so
i think i think it makes sense i think
i'm understanding it right so the
investigation is done and a report
is given to one individual commissioner
right commissioner a commissioner
that commissioner decides
whether or not
what does that commissioner decide to
determine whether or not there should be
a hearing determines whether there's
probable cause or no probable cause
moving it along in the process so if
there's probable cause it goes to a
hearing right it means there's
sufficient evidence to push it along if
the commissioner finds there's no
probable cause
it means there's insufficient evidence
to move it on the process the case gets
dismissed
right so uh miss chase had her hand up
i'm going to let her
okay well i'll i'll let mrs chase go
first because she had her hand up first
time i'll go over to representatives
i was just going to ask representatives
if that made sense or if you just want
another another human with a voice to
take a whack at explaining that
okay is that do you have anything to
clarify no i would i would just add that
in my experience
and i don't
i haven't actually talked to
um the what's called the investigating
commissioner who actually issues the pc
determination
but
and and maybe um either sarah ronnie can
correct me if i'm wrong but in my
experience the
the it seems that the investigating
commissioner just reads the report
that's prepared by the commission's
employee investigator
and
decides whether it looks
decent and rubber stamps it
based on the investigators
recommendations so there's not
i don't i don't think the investigating
commissioner takes an active role in the
investigation or in the
the determination beyond reviewing the
report
representative smith
thank you
what would happen
if there were no
human
relations commission
and if someone
let me rewrite in a more positive way
what is the reason
to have
a human relations commission rather
than
to
expect the aggrieved party
to go
to the
judicial system
if the human relations commission exists
in order
to
more appropriately more efficiently more
effectively more accurately
meet the needs of the aggrieved party
in reality is that what is happening
or would it be possible without the
human relations commission that
that the judicial branch
would get to this matter in a in
a speedier way i'm going to take a stab
at this and let megan tell me why i'm
wrong if that's okay representative
you speak more
yes thank you
um the human rights commission was
obviously established
um for
people who felt that they were
discriminated against in the workplace
and i think
it might be a little bit of a lost fact
that if someone has a discrimination
complaint
that they believe they were
discriminated against in the workplace
they must start at the human rights
commission they must start at the human
rights commission and i think that
yeah see
um
you know i i will say um
and i don't mean this disrespectfully at
all i some of our members have perhaps
facetiously said abolish the hrc and
have everyone go to court that has been
you know a
something that i have heard from some of
our members who practice in employment
law um i i do think that there
you know is um
merit to this to the system and we would
love to work on improving it for the the
reasons that we've outlined in here does
that answer your question
you could add something
that
in looking at the the creation that
legislative history
detailing the creation of the commission
based on my research the commission was
established to be a place
where
everybody could go
and get a remedy
for for human rights discrimination
violations regardless of how much you
made regardless of whether an attorney
could afford to represent you
in in my view
it it
it is a pla it should be a place
where the employee
that's being harassed at work but not
necessarily suffering a wage loss
which accumulates
value for the case
um economically um can can go
to ask for the harassment to stop
um that's you can't effectively
practically
go to a court
for that i don't in my view because the
court process takes
as a pro se litigant and
um
as a matter of
economics it's it's
it
some of these cases are are um
you know lower wage lower income earners
um with injuries that that don't
necessarily support
a private attorney
um being able to
to work to help these people
and the commission it could be
with with better
regs and a more streamlined process
could be a place where these folks
could
get a streamlined pc investigation
that's limited to pc
that they could then get the pc finding
and one thing that's being missed too is
that after the pc finding
the parties have the right to conduct
discovery including interrogatories and
depositions
after the pc findings so it's not as if
you know the employer is suddenly stuck
with the pc finding and can't conduct
any discovery there the rules provide
for discovery
uh prior to hearing which looks like a
trial
okay
but that the commission
if it if it worked a little bit better
could be a place for poorer workers
people with smaller claims
um to get justice
but right now it's just not functioning
that way
i i agree with you completely i think
the legislature agrees with you
completely i believe that is why
the commission was created in the first
place
and
it seems to me if i'm being harassed
on wednesday the 14th of september
of 2022
it does not do me very much good to know
that by the 14th of september
in
maybe
we will get to a probable
cause
which just says in fact maybe there's a
problem when you've been living with the
problem
not only for the
the two years that you've been since you
filed but for the time before that when
you hesitated to file because you hoped
you wouldn't have to file
so
if we are in agreement that that is why
the human re the human rights commission
exists
and why these cases shouldn't go to
court and why they should be available
to people with limited means
and but with serious problems
how can we support
a system
that
that has carved in stone
an incredibly
long
time period
if you're i have
opinions on that if you'd like to hear
them well i guess
we can we can get into that as we as we
go through the process because i'm
trying to keep things we get a lot of
ground to cover um and so i would just
uh director malachi had her hands up so
i'd like to recognize her
yes thank you so there are a couple of
things i think that are lost in the
conversation so far so the commission is
the attorneys present are only focused
on on employment that's not all that we
do that's one portion so if we're not
here then there's not somewhere for
someone to go for housing or public
accommodation we don't care how much
money you make so to
a comment that was made earlier it
doesn't matter if you're a busboy a
cleaning lady or the former president of
the company we don't have a vested
interest in how much that person earns
and that doesn't move how we move our
cases um if that person comes to us and
they and the law has been broken then we
are looking at that initially we're
taking
we're taking the complaint on the
grounds of what the person who walked in
the door has said to us
and
by and large um
things things are are true but there are
sometimes people who are upset
and for whatever happened to them and
maybe that employer actually did the
right thing and it was a
non-discriminatory reason that whatever
that outcome was
happened or in their housing it was
non-discriminatory but that person feels
like they've been discriminated against
if we were to have it come in and we
docket it and then we just say it's
probable cause because you told us so
then we have now eliminated the rights
of the other party to plead their case
to say well wait a minute this is what
really happened according to their
perspective um the other part that is um
i think really
important to say that once a party has
received notice um it's up if it's if
the person is represented by council
that's on the council if they choose to
wait until we have um an investigator
that's a sign that's their personal
choice if they want to wait that long
but we send out notifications that say
if you have um if you want to do
depositions if you want to do discovery
if you want to take statements and and
notarize them and send them in please by
all means do you don't need to wait
until there is an investigator now if
that was something that happened in the
past i i there's nothing in our let me
let me restate that there's nothing in
our
rules that state that you need to wait
for anything
the rules are very clear attorneys are
very smart and they can read those rules
and and apply that knowledge to sending
the information along we will collect
all of it and then move those cases
along as quickly as we possibly can
again
if the problem
from the beginning this the commission
has had a few employees and large case
loads and when they finally got six i
think it was in the 80s through the 90s
and then 2011 it was cut down and so
with the lower number of um
investigators that is at the beginning
of when the numbers started to creep up
so i think it's great that we're able to
take in and and also um finish that
number of cases per year would we do
more if we had more staff of course we
would then you can assign more cases
out of the files excuse me out of the
cases that are waiting so you have more
people which is turning over more cases
whether it's mediation
whether it's conciliation whether it's
hearings whatever it is those are those
are being walked through a lot faster
all right um representative lorenzo
thank you mr chair and i have um
a question that i'd like to pose and it
is that
throughout all this process you know
while all these whales are turning and
are not turning and you know
what about um
stopping acts of discrimination
you know um
when we have people meeting for
conciliation or mediation um
there's no penalty for um
for breaking
the rules or breaking the law as far as
i can see in this process
and so
what i would like to see and what i
would envision would be
um
some sort of like
punishment whether it's fines or um
maybe injunctions
or what they call you know just
forcing
the employer
to stop whatever they're doing like
right now and that's not
we do have power for injunctive relief
which we would work with the
attorney general's office to do that and
um i mean there is if you want to call
it a fine if there's a mediation or a
conciliation there's money that's being
paid out so they are being i guess you
could call it fined for that activity
there's a negotiation there certainly
and um
that's part of the process uh during a
hearing there are administrative fines
that the commissioners can assess um
it's a if it's a first offense ten
thousand dollars a second offense i
believe it's
twenty five thousand if it's a third
offense fifty thousand um but it's at
the discretion of the commissioners
if they do assess a fine and all of
those funds
outside of a mediation or conciliation
that goes directly to the complainant
but if there are fines assessed that
goes back into the general fund
thank you
all right uh i had a quick i just want
to pull it back to uh
the fact sheet again so
just um
as i said earlier
looking at this if we took away the
right of the respondent to remove
um that means now
that coming into your conciliation
process which is because they can't move
it anymore i think based on this data
i'm looking at about six to seven
additional cases that would have to go
through that process on an annual basis
so is it is it your belief
at the commission that that is something
that you could absorb or is that
something that you think you don't have
the resources to handle
we can absorb that we do have the
resources to handle that okay
that the next question that i would have
then kind of goes into um i i forget who
made the the uh the comment so i'll
i can't give proper credit but um
everything does indeed have to start at
the human rights commission so even if
something is a very complex case
and you know you're talking to your
lawyer and you're saying wow this is
this is something that really we need
complex discovery here
but it has to go to the human rights
commission so i just put that
in light of that
uh revelation which was you know for me
came out of the discussions that we had
um
would
just saying hey
you can choose the form out of the
get-go if you have a very complex case
and you think that the human rights
commission is
not the place for it
would getting rid of that
180 days
be of harm and and would it also um
take away perhaps some of the complexity
that goes before the commission so what
would be your thoughts if we were to
amend the statute that that part of 354
to just say hey pick your form don't
wait 180 days
thank you um so there's a couple of
pieces but the quick answer to the
question and assistant director burke
cohen will will clean up anything on
alp5 if that if there if i drop some if
i drop a jar of pickles um
take it so let me start at the end of
that one so
the 180 days yes that is statutory
however
what is also in the statute is if the
person
they must dock it with us yes so in
employment
public exceeding employment public
accommodation and housing you must
public education you have a choice of
forum which means you can file with us
or you can go to court okay
in the in employment because that's sort
of is where we're mostly focused one if
that person has an attorney that's with
them and the attorney files it or they
file with us and they pick up an
attorney and it's within the 180 days
they simply need to say hi commission
i'm now represented by council so
um attorney bert cohen is my counsel and
attorney bert cohen says we would like
to remove it to court and it's been 30
days
the commission
will say
thank you very much here's the
withdrawal form and we will close our
case
so it's not a burden to the complainant
because we don't create a barrier yes
the statute says that but right below it
it says but you may request
and we allow them to request to remove
so any attorney that practices before us
especially those for the complainant
know that if they would like to remove
it to court at any time they are welcome
to do that and they simply need to
notify us and they can do it
okay one more and just to add on so
oftentimes we do have attorneys who
have evaluated their case when they take
it and feel very strongly about their
case and do
remove it within that that time period
i've had attorneys file a case one day
and the next day file with me you know
file a letter saying hey i want to
remove it now
to address your complex case you know if
there's a complex case
um we have oftentimes attorneys won't
remove their cases even if they are a
complex until they have gotten a
probable cause finding from the
commission so sometimes that bogs us
down in and of itself we can't force a
complainant out if it's a complex case
we've had some complex tenure cases that
have gone through we've had complex
other employment types of employment
cases that have come through our office
and we can't force a complainant to
remove so we investigate it that takes a
significant amount of time if it's
complex reviewing you know documents
reviewing personnel files reviewing
statistics and data so we can't force
people out a lot of times cases that are
complex will stay with us until a
probable cause finding is found so that
does take up an investigator's time
because if you have if you're
investigating a case and you have you
know personnel files you have to review
that are like
each person's been there 20 years it's
going to take a significant amount of
time um and to add one little tidbit
part of the reason that that happens is
because we are free discovery
the attorneys that are filing they don't
have to pay for the discovery in the
investigation that we do and we we
provide them with a complete report of
of what it was they have information
from both sides so anything we request
from one party they must be they must
send it to the other party as well so we
are providing discovery services i mean
obviously that's what we do because
that's part of our investigation but
that's something that if it's an
attorney file case that the attorney
does not have to do so if they go
through our process for the most part
and then pull it right before we've done
probable cause or immediately after
not allowing it to continue to go
through the process and i'm speaking
specifically of complainants attorneys
they're using the process i mean i guess
that's fine but that's part of it as
well yeah i mean i'd like to i'd like to
follow up on that in a little bit um but
i'd like to move on though so
representative smith
very much um
so are are you saying that for
the complainants
who are able to retain an attorney
there is
one lane
as compared with
complainants
who do not have the resources
to hire an attorney
no
same lane
just attorneys understand the rules and
if they want to take it and remove it to
court they can it's not that the
complainant or the person who's not
represented doesn't have an explanation
of what the rules are if they wanted to
and they're savvy and they want to
remove it and go to court they're well
welcome to do that okay so there's not
separate rules could i just follow
quickly thank you very much
um
this
how do you establish
your priorities i and the reason i ask
is because i'm not sure how you you've
said
several times
that it's first in first out
but
i don't understand how that could be
if
you have first in
but case a only can get to
first base and meanwhile you have case b
that might get to second base
what does first in first out really mean
as a charge is docketed with the
commission
it is then
put in line with the rest of the cases
and if the case that if sarah has a
caseload of 10 cases and she's moving
all of those cases along some of the
cases in her caseload they may mediate
that case is done but we're talking in
the terms of it being assigned to an
investigator what happens once it's
assigned there's a variety of things so
someone might choose to mediate before
the investigation starts or
maybe their attorney may decide to
remove it someone else in her caseload
it may go all the way through and it may
end up in conciliation and they continue
on through our process so so what you're
saying is
you take cases
in the order they are received
that's the in part correct but that
really has nothing to do
with the out part in terms of final
disposition because each case then has
its own right its own speed it's going
through the process so it's not really
first in first out it's
in in the order that the cases come
they're taken in the order that they
come right and every case has the same
process
some will
leave the leave our process sooner based
on whatever decision
if it's represented by council and they
want to remove it to court if there's a
mediation whether they're represented or
not so there's a variety of ways that it
can leave us
yes miss chase yeah i i just want to um
agree
that it is possible for the uh plaintiff
to remove the charge from the commission
prior to 80 days by sending a request
for for release um from to the
commission and um i haven't heard of the
commission
um denying such requests the pro as a
practical matter
i think what what can happen and which
has happened anecdotally
is
complainant files charge
we
a deadline is set for the defendant to
set to answer the charge which is always
very valuable to uh to the complainant
to know how the defendant what the
defendant's version of events is right
versus the allegations
and
um
in of late i'm noticing that defense the
defense bar has picked up
on the lethargy
of the commission so they're not they're
not they're just they're just not
reacting
um to the deadline set
by the commission
so the complainant is
stuck waiting for an answer or waiting
for information from uh in waiting
for information which the investigator
has requested
um
and
by then it's 180 days in the meantime
um
you know it's possible that the
investigator isn't even assigned for a
year
so
to get the value of the commission you
you
yes you do want an investigator assigned
and you do want information from the
defendant some information before you
remove in my experience in both most
cases
so yes it's true that you can remove
you must file at the commission period
you cannot elect to not file a
commission
it is true that you can remove
prior to the 180 day mark that is true
but it's it's not
generally helpful
to do so because you at least want an
answer
um
from the defendant which would happen in
your typical personal injury plan
right it would happen in court right so
so if
if that's the case i'm not a lawyer so
bear with me
if that's the case
um and they always accede
to the request at the commission the
commission always received a seeds to
the request
what is the value in keeping the 180
days
um
is there any value in keeping the 180
days
um i i think that
the reason why the 180-day deadline was
was um
established was to
give
the
employer the benefit of at least some
investigation before allowing allowing
the plain complainant to proceed
um but you know we're we're not seeing
that a whole lot of investigation is
happening before 180 days
so i guess the answer that question is
no and i don't see any value and in
other areas except to get the answer
representative i mean i would like to
get
like
there's yes um let me think about your
question your question is
do we should we have it written into the
statute that you have to stay
for 180 days if by commission rule
you're allowed to to
remove before then
or it may be that may be written into
the statute i can't remember where i
just i mean
the the language of the statute i put it
in the handout yeah so it's
you know choice of forum you go to the
uh 354 a colon
21 slash a choice of forum so i'm not a
lawyer i think this is the relevant part
of the statute if i'm wrong you can kind
of correct me
but i think it says uh
or sooner if the commission ascends in
writing but not later than three years
after the alleged unlawful practice it's
in the statute so so it is there and i'm
just wondering if
if you're with your client and you
review your case
and you decide that
superior court is the way to go if the
folks at the human rights commission are
going to accede to your request
why why do we need this
and and is it gonna
is it gonna help streamline the process
to just get rid of it
i don't know the answer to question to
the second part of your question but i
think that
i i think that this the the language and
the statute sets a deadline that's not
really a deadline
right or a mandatory stay requirement
that's not really a mandatory stay
because it's by its own language and and
they they they are seed 100 of the time
right i mean have you ever can you think
of a case
director malachi will you have not
exceeded
um not to my knowledge but the point of
it too is the percentage of attorney
represented um complainants is small
so those that are going to
leave are small
so whether you keep it or whether you
take it away it is small
so it doesn't streamline or change
anything and let's say it's not there
and there's a true choice of forum
the busboy is not going to court
okay
all right any other thoughts on that
all right so
so what i'd like to do then i'm just
looking at the time so
um i'd like to get into a little bit of
the discussion about the process
and as as part of that uh
bring into that the whole
discussion about you know what is the
threshold for a probable cause finding
uh one of the things you know director
malachi you talk about is the fact that
attorneys are using commission to do
research for complex cases because
probable kind the probable cause finding
is
really that there's a lot that goes into
it say in in contrast to maybe going
into court or something like that but
before i get into that i just kind of
want to follow up on a comment that
representative dilorenzo uh said and i
just wanted to kind of plumb your
thoughts on that so
it sounds from some of the discussion
that we've had today
that right now the commission is at a
place where it's kind of level loaded
right so we got 240 cases in 240 cases
out
but because of
the backlog that the accumulation that
has built up over time
um it just stays there it's like a big
pimple that you can't bust right so um
so
but representative dilorenzo was kind of
saying what about uh
using the attorney general's office
as investigators and so i was you know
while you may be adequately staffed to
level load
is their value perhaps and saying hey we
have this
backlog
and we're going to need some help with
that
so have you had any discussions or any
thoughts to that regard basically deal
with that backlog
um so to some degree um the civil rights
unit which would be the most logical
place to do any sort of um shared work
and there is no staffing there to do
that we are the staff that does the
majority of the work so to speak um and
there as far as i
um can
ascertain in speaking with
our aag sean locke there there aren't
investigative staff that would be able
to take this on so
whether you're adding and the
investigators there are retired police
officers which is great but the pay
level is significantly higher than what
we offer so then you get into that
conversation where you have our
investigators doing this those
investigators doing the exact same job
making maybe a i don't know half
a half more than what the current
investigators are
that's a whole nother conversation but
that's part of it
uh all right thanks for that so i think
then if
if nobody has any additional comment on
that i think i'd like to go into
the last part of the formal agenda which
is kind of going through
um
the process um and
some discussions around the process uh
there is a memorandum that was uh put
out um by the association for justice
and um it kind of talks about basically
setting up some structure uh
bringing that timeline into a one-year
timeline but i just want to follow up a
little bit on
uh
representative gordon's comments so it's
a recommendation but if they're
if the resources are what the resources
are and and they're level loaded
how do we kind of break through that
practically
and you know
do we need to
revisit
what is
the probable cause threshold
because it's very different my
understanding
from superior court versus the human
rights commission or does it need to
stay where it is because
the folks that go before the commission
are resource constrained so i think i'd
like to to start
just by having you folks go through
your memorandum your thoughts on that um
i know it went out to director malachi a
couple days ago i don't know if she had
a chance to look at it in any real
detail but if she has i'd like to give
her an opportunity to respond to that
and then we can kind of get into some
open discussion so i'll let you guys
take it away first
so um megan douglas and samantha hearing
worked on this um this memo and do you
want to kind of talk through your
thoughts about how the structure is yeah
um
the
so the the commission
established by rule establishes what
probable cause means what it is
what it is is uh sufficient evidence
from which a reasonable
fact-finder
could
find discrimination that's a slight
paraphrase because we can call it the
maybe standard there may be
discrimination here
um yeah that that um there could be a
could be standard okay
um
and the commission rules i'll also say
that
uh issues of disputed fact are to be
reserved
for
the commission at hearing so to the
extent that
uh the the plaintiff says one thing um
happened and the employer says a
different thing happened
the the the investigator is is supposed
to leave resolution of that
to the commission
um
and and what so what does this
so if you're an investigator what what
do you have to do
well you have to look at the law
and the law in these cases follows
what's called typically follows what's
called the mcdonald douglas standard
it's a three-pronged
um analysis
and
um
there's a primo fascia phase that's the
first prong
prima fascia means um
basic
on the pha on its face first face
um and and
there the employee uh if we're talking
about an employment case i do understand
that there's public accommodations and
housing cases at the commission
but if we're talking about employment it
the primo fascia case requires the
plaintiff to establish that they are of
a protected class meaning they're
um
they they're of a race
they are of a national origin there they
have a gender
and uh that
they
i wish i could find my paper because my
cheat sheet because i think it would be
helpful at this juncture
um
that they have been that they allege
that they have been
um suffered an adverse action or hostile
environment because of that race that's
the primo fascia case
then the next phase is um
what the employee employee side calls
the pretext
phase
what the employer would call the
legitimate reason for adverse action
phase okay
um
at that phase the employer has the
burden of raising
um
some basis
for the bad thing that the employee
alleges happened to them as a result of
their protected status
right some base some legitimate basis
that's not the protected status
okay that justifies the action the the
harsh or critical or unpleasant action
they took okay
um
and then at the third
phase
the employee has to have
um the right
to
submit evidence that says you know what
that thing that the employer said
um
was was legitimate
that's all phony baloney that's not true
that's a cover-up that's a
you know a cover your bottom
um
excuse
okay
that's the rebuttal so we've got primo
fascia
legitimate reason
plaintiff's rebuttal
in my view what the investigators should
be doing
is they should be looking at these three
phases and they should be asking
themselves
first
is there some credible evidence that the
plaintiff is of a protected class
and that they suffered
a wrong
okay
that's is there some evidence of that
second
phase looking to the employer
is there some credible evidence
that
they you know that they took the action
for a legitimate reason
whatever it is the employee complained
of
if the employer
does not raise that
then the pc cause should issue
immediately
okay
but however what what usually happens is
the employer comes up with an excuse
admittedly okay so
the investigator says all right i have
some credible evidence of that now
employee
tell me
why this is not
this excuse that the employer has raised
why this is not valid
give me a witness
that will will rebut
the validity of this give me a document
give me an email give me a text give me
something
if the employee comes up with something
that's credible
the pc finding should issue because
remember
that the issues of the the ultimate the
ultimate decision is supposed to go to
the fact finder
the the investigators analysis should be
limited to is there some credible
evidence to satisfy the complainant's
burden in the mcdonald
douglas burden shifting framework and
respectfully i feel like that i've
noticed i'll use better words that the
investigators are going beyond that i
think i think they're overreaching which
is what's causing these
two three year long investigations
and i think that we should let we should
let employees be heard
the employer has the ability as director
maliki pointed out earlier they have the
ability to conduct discovery they have
access to
actually employers usually have most of
the evidence because they're the
business
right
employees don't own their emails
sometimes they don't even own their
texts that they use at work
um
and sometimes they're not savvy enough
to take good notes as to what's
happening and sometimes hr departments
are
so the employer
has the stuff they're they're really
i don't see
why if an employee has been able to come
forth with some credible evidence
supporting their case why we're not
letting more cases go go to hearing
and what's happening now is even the
ones that are able to meet
that
the the investigatory standards that the
commission is applying
they're still having to go through it
all again in court some of them that are
removed
and
that's what sb 296 is trying to fix
thanks director malachi do you have a
chance to look at that and have any
thoughts i do
so the three
areas that
attorney douglas mentioned
that is our investigative process so
i mean maybe she put it in smaller words
but that is how we do our process so
that's her desire or her
thoughts on how it should work is how it
works now
um
the way that the statute is written
right now so uh and a um
a respondent is noticed that there's
been a charge of discrimination
the way the statute is written
if they choose not to participate they
don't have to they can not give us
anything until there's a public hearing
that would be their choice not a wise
decision because what we what would we
do then is your question anything that
the complainant says happened to them we
deemed that admitted and that's a really
easy breezy probable cause because
there's nothing from the other party to
refute what was stated
and um and so she attorney douglas
eloquently discussed the the pendulum
that we use basically that swings back
and forth
the complainant says one thing the
respondent has an opportunity to respond
it goes back to the complainant to give
us a witness an email or something
sometimes those who are represented
who may
have
people that they would like to call as
witnesses either they're unable or
unwilling to provide that information to
us we will do our our very best to reach
out to those people but if they've taken
statements then it would be helpful to
provide those to us or contact
information we'll certainly reach out to
both parties to gather that information
to then move our investigation along so
the issue here really isn't
the investigative process it moves along
at a at a much better pace so previously
to the statement that
the investigation does i'm not talking
about pending cases
so speaking to what
attorney douglas stated
the way that our reports were written
before they were very long and the way
they were written before they were going
basically to a hearing standard which is
a much higher bar
to prove probable cause
what what i've done is look at it with
the help of the staff and we've actually
put the reports the report writing and
the investigation that the that the
investigator is doing back to where it
is or where it should be which was a
probable cause standard so you have
prima facie just getting in the door
probable cause is a little bit higher
and then 50 plus one percent which is
what you deal with at a hearing that is
a much higher standard we have put the
standard back where it's supposed to be
so if you as a complainant have
something and it's the rebuttal time
that shows okay i think this this looks
like it's enough to get to probable
cause then we're finding probable cause
if you say as a as a complainant
well there's some witnesses out there
and you're not able to give us any
contact information or names or there's
no way for us to find the person and all
you have is bob well if we've requested
the records from the employer and we can
sort of figure out it might be bob moore
but there's seven bobs we'll try to
reach out to bob but if you don't have
any way to help us then how are we to
know which bob it is that was present at
the time of whatever the incident was
that happened
so
in a nutshell
um
we this the process that was described
is the process that we use
the pending time is the time that is
what is distressing everyone not the
investigation time
anytime that there's an amendment to a
charge we must start our process from
the beginning and you give all the
parties an opportunity to respond to
that so that elongates the investigation
time but the pending time is what the
issue is not the investigation time
those can take up to a year some or less
than that some are a little bit longer
but on average it's about a year maybe
less
so um yeah and so this timeline in the
timeline it doesn't take the the pending
into account because it's basically
assigning the investigator in the first
quarter
so um so you you mentioned that you had
already
shifted uh the probable cause standard
to match the statute that that
in the past it had been at a hearing
level
um did i understand that correctly
the so the investigators certainly were
doing a thorough investigation but what
they were having to
the the determination level that they
were required was a much higher burden
and it shouldn't have been that high it
was re it was put back where it was
supposed to be so probable cause became
a 50 plus one standard
instead of
it's more than likely something happened
so one of the things i i was kind of
asking for when i met with
you guys
a few weeks back
was
just just looking um
for
i was asking about the length of the the
investigation process and so
as part of that discussion you know
saying hey it could be here it could go
up to two years it kind of runs the
gamut do you have do you have any data
that kind of says this is what my
investigation time was prior to that
realignment um and what that
investigation time was after just so we
could kind of get a feel for uh
has there been any shifts
in the in the timeline
i don't have
um
i don't have that specifically yeah
but what i i do have anecdotally is in
working with the staff um the report
writing so the number of reports that
are coming in
have have increased um and the report
writing isn't taking as long because uh
sometimes you get up 10 pages of a
report right and and there's
just
10 pages of a report the reports are a
bit more condensed but all of the
information is there we put in the
report the legal standard that's being
used so whether the person is
represented by council or not they will
understand what it is we've done and the
standard that they did or did not meet
whichever party it is so it's very
clearly stated in paragraph form
it's a it's less
dense and a bit easier to consume
it would it would really help as we're
going to really understanding where the
roadblocks are in the process
if we kind of had
a break-in date as to when there was
that realignment of the process and if
you have data that says this is my
investigation time prior to that
break-in date this is the investigation
time after you know it's it's a way to
just kind of assess how effective that
has been and and it would give us you
know on the committee a feel just yeah
actually this is this is on the right
track and really
the the barrier here really is the
backlog we're level loaded we're
actually seeing the investigation time
come down and so that might actually
start to shift things on its own
or actually no it hasn't so we're going
to stay level loaded for a long time
with that backlog going on so i think i
think if we could get that data that
would be
for me
just my personal thought i i'd like to
see if there's a process shift there so
i don't know how easy that would be to
get but it would be welcome
i'm not sure either but i'm gonna try
you know i just had a couple questions
uh uh
on the commissioners themselves
i i only recognize one name on there but
how many of the commissioners are
attorneys
it depends
i mean you mean currently or in general
currently uh we have one attorney and we
have one jd
right now
out of seven
and
is it very common for them to deny
a request from an investigator to find
probable cause
uh not usually i mean if there's
questions or if there's an issue
those are discussed
and
i was trying to figure out what their
qualifications were to
determine probable cause that was they
understand the legal standard they've
had a training to understand that we
have the ag's office to assist us um and
the the
i don't think that the issue is you're
not able to do this work if you're not
an attorney
there are plenty of people in our office
who are not attorneys who do this work
every day
and you also run the case you also run
the issue of the attorneys that would
potentially be on the commission
would more than would potentially be
attorneys attorneys that could practice
before us which means they couldn't be
on the commission
so you would still have if it was
attorneys that you're looking at they
would have to be someone in some other
field that has nothing to do with what
we do which still means they'd have to
understand the legal standard they would
still have to
take a training to understand what it is
we do and how we evaluate cases
if i could ask some additional questions
so
when
a probable cause determination is made
and there were to be a hearing
at that point in time who prosecutes
that hearing is it the
investigator or is it the individual
complainant that prosecutes them
um if i understand what you're asking we
have a hearing panel and there are three
commissioners that are on the the
hearing panel if the person and these
commissioners are not any none of them
are ones that were involved in the fact
finding of the initial
charge the determination
with that said
if one party if the complainant is not
represented by council then by statute
the commission puts on the case for the
unrepresented
complainant
so in circumstances where we were not to
we were not to allow employers to remove
to the court
and they were unrepresented that would
put some additional burden on the
commission with regard to
the responsibility for prosecuting the
complaint
there would be responsibility on the
commission for
representing
the the unrepresented individual
but that would happen regardless so if
it means we need to
adjust
who that person who that individual is
because there's not something currently
in statute then i don't think that's a
heavy lift
follow up
so
in
listening to attorney douglas basically
in terms of the probable cause
investigation she mentioned
the
initial the uh complainant is going to
file the complaint per se which i'm
presuming is under oath at the time
and
so they file a complaint
the employers
and that's the burden is on the
complainant to do that
that's not something the commission does
so then
the employer is given the opportunity to
respond
and i'm presuming that the burden is on
the employer
to do that work and not the commission
and then
they provide
an explanation for why they did whatever
they did
and then the third prong is
the
then the complainant gets to respond to
the employer
i'm presuming again and the burden is
again on the complainant not on the
commission to provide that information
and then as as i understand the
testimony
the investigator then looks at
these three circumstances three
documents whatever whatever has been
provided the evidence has been provided
and makes a determination as to
whether
not as to whether or not the facts are
accurate
a determination of facts but makes a
determination as to whether or not it
would legally qualify
by virtue of probable cause
that you could make a probable cause
determination that the law was that
basically the law was broken
is that a fair
assessment
i
i'm a little confused by the tail end of
that because we're at probable cause so
we're not assessing whether the law was
actually broken that's at a public okay
the supreme court has set a standard for
probable cause so and which is less than
more likely than not but greater than a
reasonable suspicion correct so
if i'm following what you're saying
the commission essentially facilitates
everything throughout right we
facilitate we take the charge in we tell
the respondent to give us an answer
respondent gives us an answer we tell
the complainant to give us a rebuttal
you send them send them a letter right
so we facilitate that we review
everything and then make a determination
from there looking at the evidence
talking we also you know interview
witnesses along the way interview
complainant we have to interview any
specifically named party so we interview
all those folks and take all of that
evidence in
and use it to determine that probable
cause
is that what you're i guess i'm not sure
what specifically you're looking for if
okay i i guess what i'm trying to look
at is why
why
if you're not making factual
determinations
why
the burden is on the commission
to do interviews with witnesses at that
point in time as opposed to
taking the information that's been
provided to you by the litigants
to make a determination of probable
cause not a determination of whether
a final determination but just a
determination of probable causes to go
forward
so
to some extent i understand what you're
saying
um you're looking to see if we are
making factual determinations during a
probable cause investigation which are
the the short answer is we use our
witness testimony right because
sometimes in other pro se complainants
they're submitting rebuttals that don't
actually answer the question or rebut
anything right
so we interview those folks to talk to
them about what the rebuttal like
your employer said this about you know
this is what your employer said i asked
you for a rebuttal and it it was about
this hearing today and so talk to me
about your time there because part of
another component of the mcdonald
douglas test and employment cases
is whether a an employee is is
performing adequately at their job and
performing their job right so we look at
that too so we talked to them about hey
are you performing adequately what were
you doing at your job were you at work
if it's an absenteeism case were you
absent
you know were you absent why were you
absent was it if it's a disability
related absence were you absent because
of that or not because we have a lot of
pro se folk that can't
don't understand how to put a rebuttal
in writing so
yes we need to interview those people
to make a determine to to find out what
their actual rebuttal is
just one more follow-up and that is
but
do you need that to make a determination
of probable cause why would you not rely
on the information that's provided to
you
by the litigants to make the
determination probable cause and then if
in fact there is probable cause
to do that
investigation
to determine whether or not there is
ultimately merit to the case which would
require you ultimately to prosecute the
case on behalf of the libya
so
as attorney douglas says we're looking
at all credible evidence so part of that
is
talking to people to determine whether
the evidence is submitted is credible
sometimes that's determining that an
employer is submitting to submitting
documents that weren't actually in a
complainant's personnel file did you
receive this document no i didn't
okay so that puts that puts something in
our like wait maybe those documents
aren't credible so part of it is
determining that whether the evidence
that we are receiving is credible
thank you mr chair
any other questions representative
walper
representative smith
i guess
the investigators take as long as we're
taking to try to figure out where we are
it's no wonder it goes on for two years
because we're sure
befuddled here
i guess i would like to ask
uh to go back to the fact sheet for a
minute okay if i could
and ask
well not the faction i'm sorry i mean
the memorandum
um
and asked
what would cause you to believe
but the time limits that you have you
have these very detailed descriptions of
each quarter
what would make you think that the
that the human rights commission would
be
any
better
able
to honor this
schedule than the schedule that
already exists
well
i i maybe i'm wrong but i i thought i
just heard director malachi say that
investigations are already taking about
a year
so
if that's accurate then this can be done
and i think that's where um
getting the data you know would would
i really be interested to see if there
was a shift in where they're putting the
probable cause threshold just to kind of
see has has that investigative period
shrunk
along with that and i think that would
be
really important data just to understand
what is the impact and where it where is
the real log jam because you're right
director malachi you did say
that
we're here we're on board
chunk by chunk by chunk this is our
process so i i think i would like to see
that data and let's let's just take a
look at it i just follow up because i
you really confused me because
i thought
that what this was
was a
a division of time
in which to resolve
the matter
not a division of time in which to do
the initial
investigation
so where am i wrong and i'm just saying
um
you know
i think that now is a great time to
remember that the fact that this is so
complicated really speaks again to how
difficult it is for people to get
justice
i just want to lay that out there it's
very complicated and it doesn't need to
be that complicated this is
investigation should take
no more than a year and a hearing should
be scheduled within 60 days after that
that's my that's my notion of of a
reasonable
um time frame
why do you say resolve the charge
i think
maybe that's poorly representative uh
but i think it's it says here the
at the the end product of the timeline
that eternally douglas has
put out is the consumer can then review
the investigative report and issue a
probable cause determination by the
final day of the fourth quarter so the
product
at the end of the year is the probable
cause determination
then the paragraph at the beginning the
introductory paragraph is perhaps a
little misleading
um the one that paragraph that
immediately precedes the first quarter
so i think i think
as as i read the document the the the
product being asked to be delivered at
the end of this four quarter cycle
is the probable cause finding and
director malachi you were saying that
that's something that you you've looked
at and you've already incorporated this
so i think at this point i just would
like to see
where are we at now
that is if that is now our current state
what is that doing for us and so i think
that would be good data to have
because i believe
from your testimony that that is current
state so let's look at that
except
that if all we're doing in a full year
is
what i see as
establishing the threshold
there's something wrong with the process
and i want to say
representative gordon
and
and if
and and may and again i'm probably wrong
again i don't know but
if
if what we're agreeing is okay it's okay
now if the investigations are only
taking a year
the question is when are the
investigators getting assigned before
they take the year you know that's
another whole issue so
uh and that's if we're only doing half
the cases at a time that's right so well
that doesn't seem to be working for me
but that's uh well that and and that is
that is the big question so where do we
focus our resources do we
is it really an investigation issue is
it really
uh the wait time on getting the
investigators assigned so i think
that's what we got to figure out well
this and i think part of it is i'm
getting too old
and i have this limited horizon now
in terms of my life and so every every
year is dear to me right now and when i
look at this process i say if i was a
litigant and i had a complaint with my
employer
i would think i would be able to resolve
that complaint within one year
and the state should have a process in
place that says
if i have that complaint i can get some
type of answer within a year and to
think that i have to go two years or
more at this point in time i think
is uh
is
is a is a
an insult to those workers out there
that have the process
and it seems to me that we can
streamline that probable cause process
to make it work
and and do it in a time frame i think
government is failing the people in the
state of new hampshire in the way it's
doing it right now
representative wilpert
so i have to totally agree with
representative gordon on this right
to me
and
representative smith said the same thing
and if we're going to take a year
to find out whether you can even really
have hearing about
to
have your case heard
that's not good at all
right i i would think that we should be
able to do this in a matter of
a couple of months
because
as i've read all of this the
investigator
is not responsible
for resolving
conflicts of fact
so if the employer says
a
and the employee says that isn't right
it's not up to the investigator to
determine who's telling the truth
that's not part of their job
their job is to say well if
you are telling the truth
then
there's a good case you you've got a
case and send that to the commissioner
and the commission will do the
investigation
or
carry it on and i don't see why it
should take that long at all
right and the assignment business is
just as important it doesn't do any good
to say well we could do this in three
months but i'm not going to assign it
for eight months
so you got 11 months
to get what
so
does anybody else say the other comment
on that
the goal when when we sat down with the
staff with the help of the ag's office
was to look at our internal process to
see if there are any hurdles that we
have internally whether it's intake
investigation
um moving it onto a hearing what are our
things internally if anything that are
slowing down our process
and i tasked myself and tasked the staff
with the help of the ag's office in
looking at the entire investigative
process and figuring out okay how can we
do this in six months
so
what we have right now is moving into
the process of wanting to get things
done in six months
with the current staff that i have and
they're looking at their cases and
moving those along um
we could potentially do it in six months
the issue comes back to
the cases that are pending
and how do you
if we didn't have anything coming in if
we had maybe five cases a month come in
for a year
current staff we could probably knock
out everything that's pending with the
the new process and move it along but
that's not the case so as um
representative mclean said
if you're if what's coming in is roughly
what you're closing
with the staff that you have
and that includes turnover
people moving on for whatever reasons
then
that means that that process is working
and you're going to move the process
more expediently
then what else what else can you do
well
if you limit amendments maybe or you
change
certain elements those are possibilities
but then where do you get into
taking away rights for complainants or
respondents
to be able to have their opportunity to
have their voice heard
that's for the smart people in this room
to figure out
because those are the elements of our of
our statute
and then along with that
i mean we certainly wouldn't want
any of that to happen
but looking at what's in the pending
file what's waiting to be assigned if
you have more hands in there pulling out
of the file then you're able to
move those all along putting them in the
same system in the new system or updated
system whatever you want to call it and
they're moving those cases along as as
they're finishing cases each month
they're assigned a new case each month
so nothing is sitting for a year until
they finish all the cases everyone you
close you get three or four more every
month and some people may close even
more and they'll get more cases in that
month
so we're signing out as quickly as
people are closing cases
yes miss chase
thank you representative and thank you
director malachi i that i mean that
makes sense to me as a
human um
i'm gonna ask um if it's okay with you
representative um i think that's really
interesting about changing the process
for filing amendments to claims because
megan was nodding
oh i'm sorry i'm going to ask attorney
douglas to talk about the amendments to
claims because i saw her nodding
vigorously perhaps that's an area where
we agree and i just really briefly want
to go back to the cases coming in
you know earlier we had talked about the
180-day filing period and i think you
know the whole idea of removing after
it's filed perhaps if a complainant who
is represented by an attorney
does not have to initially file with the
human rights commission if it is going
to be a complex case that they could
just file directly to superior court
that would alleviate that whole issue
that you know attorney malachi mentioned
of providing free discovery and
overburdening resources on the human
rights commission so that was just an
idea
i think that um
correct me if i'm wrong but i think that
public school students
who are victims of discrimination have a
direct path to court
whereas
adults in employment situations do not
under the statute which could be
something that could be made consistent
right
um
what what else did i oh the amendments
um as uh
look i the rules right now allow
uh
an employee to amend any time up until
probable cause finding
and i
freely avail of of that right um because
i fight very vigorously for my employees
but i recognize that that bogs down the
commission
what i think would be great is if we
preserve the right of the employee to
remove
up until the time of the probable cause
finding right
and we limit the ability to amend
because let's say i'm an employee
who didn't file a great complaint right
um and now i want to amend but my my
time my deadline for amendment is passed
under the new commission rule i i'm not
out of luck entirely i still have the
ability to go to court
right
um which is you know just
desserts for my failure to maybe file a
perfect complaint
i mean i don't know if that's the best
way to put it but it's it doesn't
completely bar somebody from relief and
it would make it would keep an expedited
um open accessible process for most
folks at the commission and in courts
actually have an amendment deadline
um as the federal court has
has an amendment deadline
um
in its in a spoiler plate
scheduling order for all civil cases
um and after that you have to show just
cause good cause for your amendment and
you might not win
right um
so that this to to limit amendments
would not be
um inconsistent with our jurisprudence
in courts
um and further if we still have the the
ability to remove to court
then we still haven't have a forum for
relief if we can't amend the commission
so director malachi you had your hand up
for that yeah just very quickly to um to
add to what attorney douglas stated you
know there is a little box on our form
that says ongoing
action
so if this is happening right now or it
was happening a few months ago and then
i've decided to file a charge i can put
that something is ongoing which means
that um and the attorneys understand
this as well which means that you don't
necessarily have to file amendments
because we will look at the things that
are included in that so maybe
once you filed your charge you didn't
have an issue of retaliation but
now it's a month later and you know uh
they have taken the information to their
attorney now you're receiving
retaliation
so technically you could you could amend
your charge for retaliation but we could
look at all of that
as a part of the whole because you have
filed your charge with us so we could
potentially look so something like that
we could potentially look at
including it
including it in in the investigation as
we're moving forward but the point is
there's a little box that says ongoing
action which gives that person a bit
more of an umbrella if they're not able
to necessarily amend a charge if that's
a decision you make
well i think i mean i think obviously
we've had a lot of talk today there's a
lot to digest
but i think
that
you know if we're not going to get
resources from the ag's office and
you're level loaded then we're going to
have to
look at something to kind of find a way
to to break that backlog up
and so i think
um
we should talk about we want to get
together again but i think when we do
get together again if the committee
agrees i think just to kind of summarize
where we're at right now um it's and i
just everybody give me feedback is
we're thinking that the original
language in 296 is okay
we think that if we take away um
the the right of removal
that
that extra amount that goes on to the
commission can be absorbed so that part
we're okay with we did follow back on
amending the 180 days in 354
just maybe consider for those with an
attorney
and then the rest of it comes down to
the process itself
and you know
is how we realigned with the statutory
definition of probable cause are we
doing that
what has been the impact from a time
perspective of that realignment
and
if
we have seen the shift then that may
help us kind of break up the log jam but
also
we're maybe open to some things within
the process such as looking at the the
ability to amend now do you find
that those cases that are at the upper
end are amendment rich
um
not necessarily those that are pending
but um but the ones that have a long
investigation time so yes and those are
usually our attorney filed ones okay and
so
you know
yeah okay so i think you know we look to
get together i think we're okay on the
front end of 296. we want to get back to
looking a little bit at the process i
think that's
from taking the temperature of the
committee where we're at
so
i'm like
really busy the next two weeks i do have
off next tuesday morning
um
because i have actually i'm on another
commission in the afternoon
so i have tuesday morning free mondays
free but i don't think anybody wants to
meet on monday so i have uh i have
tuesday morning free and i have all of
wednesday the following week
do either of those times work for
anybody
somebody say yes
tuesday morning doesn't
so
the the 28th
representative lorenzo
would that work for you
representative gordon
september
that's a wednesday
wednesday right
are you looking at october 28th
no 28th of september
this is today's the 14th
okay
so could we go could we go same time on
september 28th
one o'clock
okay and then hopefully we can flush it
out enough
that we'll have a you know a good
direction out of that because
representative gordon is the chairman of
the committee as a whole when do we have
to report out on this
first
week
okay
so we'll we'll really get into the meat
and potatoes on the 28th then and then
get together kind of the final product
you know what can we do what can we not
do
um
a new
what impact has it had yes
or not
well if she can i mean it's not easy to
get at
but but director malachi you said you're
going to try to go back
like i said the key thing is the
break-in date and the the investigation
durations before and after the break-in
date i mean that would be great data um
and then we can we can look at that we
can assess did have an impact that not
and then we can get into some other
things with respect to the internals of
the process
and like i said but we're like i said if
if representative gordon is looking to
get us together in the second week of
october
um
next beginning next meeting will be
pretty beefy and hopefully you know
we'll come out of it with
whatever we have yes
a quick question um
i
i made a spreadsheet
that runs from
2009 up into 2017 which was the
information that was that's on the um
hrc website and it and i did an analysis
of like cases
charges filed cases closed and then any
carry over
um
so and i noticed that
in
a few years
there were
more cases closed than there were filed
for instance in 2013 there were 225
cases filed and 283 cases closed
and that made a um
58 cases
closed more than what came in okay so
there's also like a 58 yeah um so
would it be helpful to find out what
happened in that year and why
there was a good um
uh 2013.
we can see that was before our time so
i'm not exactly sure um but we can see
what we can find out for twenty so what
would you say okay so i have 2016
charges filed
uh 235 closed there was um 46
cases
closed more than
a little bit lower
yeah because you're going to be pulling
you're going to be pulling things from
things that are waiting at this point
right so we're looking at a decade of
that process and so you're pulling from
those so you could potentially
for right now anyway always have you
know for the next few years anyway or
next year have more cases closed than
cases taken in because you're reaching
to get the ones that are waiting and get
those closed
i did have a question before we finish
if i may
um there was i i had a question and
maybe marissa and attorney douglas can
answer and maybe we're not using the
memorandum at this point but i did have
a question to um because it's maybe
something to discuss at the next
meeting the penalty mechanism i was um
i wanted to find out what the penalty
was and what the mech what the thoughts
were about that and and the mechanism of
applying um assessing a penalty who that
was what it looked like if that's okay
so
right here let's just
uh
well i mean i think we've learned with
certain other statutes that um
you know there they don't have teeth if
there's there's no
ability to enforce them
um we've had a a section of 354a that
mandates two years um beginning to end
um
at the commission and that's not
happening
um and there's no and there's no
commensurate enforcement provision and
so we were thinking maybe
something should be included in the
statute to
hold the commission accountable
for the deadline
i i i personally i you know i i it's
it's nothing personal um it really isn't
i i just
i think that
you know rules rules are only as good
i mean how many people are gonna stop at
a stop sign if you're not gonna get a
ticket i mean i i don't sounds like my
argument when we talk about immunity uh
yeah i mean i uh i don't really have
great ideas
yet about what that enforcement
mechanism would look like um
i'm not specifically
but it's not inconsistent with the idea
of providing justice and that for
example in criminal cases
we have speedy trial rules that
basically say you need to have your
trial within a reasonable period of time
because
otherwise it's just not just and
therefore
cases will be dismissed
if they're not heard and
so it's not inconsistent i think with
the idea that
justice should be administered in a
reasonable period of time
if i'm a representative and that's a
great question director malachi if i
were in your shoes i would absolutely
want details about
what is a penalty what's the enforcement
mechanism all of that so if it's okay um
i'll try to get together with our folks
and touch base with you before the next
meeting um just to share some of those
ideas off the top of my head i know in
the civil context is such a thing as a
post-judgment interest
if settlement negotiations between two
parties fail and obviously this is a
very different concept um there is an
interest on the award if you know
someone was acting in bad faith so
that's just something off the top of my
head
yes i mean if it's a financial penalty
or the staff paying this or well like
what what does that what does that look
like and
quickly
uh so mr chairman i would like to say
just one thing on in terms of that right
the department of health and human
services
sends out an enormous number of
notifications
to their um
clientele
and every one of them says if you have
not respond you do not respond to this
within
10 days or two weeks
or
by tomorrow
but they all have a very tight window
of response
and it's my thinking
that this is a thing that would expedite
the investigation process at the
commission
quite substantially
if if if they're going to the employer
will say
and they will say the employee has said
this
and you have to respond by
next tuesday
or
we're going to just
discontinue your benefits
that's what the fda says
that's what they always said
right yes
and why can't why can't the hrc do the
same thing and it works on the other
side
right you could you've said this they
said that you got to respond and if you
don't respond by next wednesday
or you know then
we're just assuming that there's no
rebuttal and we're going to use that we
do that now
so if if the complainant says all of
these things happen to me
and it's enough for us to dock at the
charge and we send notice to the
respondent
the respondent has an opportunity to
respond but according to the statute if
they choose not to respond at all that
is their right
however what we will do is we send
notification you're not responding we
will then deem everything admitted
and then it's a probable cause finding
because there's nothing to rebut that so
it's up to the respondent if they choose
to respond that's that's up to them it
it's in their best interest too because
maybe there's nothing there maybe
there's everything there it's up to them
i i
i i think that's great
i haven't experienced that and as a
matter of fact i therefore there are
attorneys in my office
who
have
not received information from
respondents
and and i think have have inquired with
investigators you know where is this
information from the respondent that was
due
and no consequence has been levied i
mean i don't know if this isn't is it
this is a um a ruled a procedure change
of of you know recently but
i know that
my colleague has told me that he's he's
had issues
getting things from the respondent and
he's sought uh relief from the
investigator and he hasn't hasn't gotten
relief
um i would need i would want to look
into that specific instance to make sure
that i speak to it appropriately but the
rule is what we've been using so they
have an opportunity to respond is that a
formalized rule director malachide you
know yes it's in our statute
excuse me i apologize it's in the rules
not the statute
i just want to make one more comment if
i could and that was and basically going
back to where i think
representative smith began at the
beginning and that is i've been very
critical of
the of the commission today and and
and i in my mind deservedly so but
not critical at all of the staff and i
just wanted to
direct him out like i just indicate that
i don't really have a problem with the
staff but i certainly have a problem
with the process and i have a problem
with the state for allowing it to
continue the way it is so
thank you
any other comments
all right so we are adjourned until
september 28th
at 1 o'clock
you